hey everybody welcome to this small
announcement video and planet coaster
what you're looking at at the moment is
completely unedited footage of the game
I didn't put this together with any
different clips whatsoever this is just
a roller coaster going on for pretty
much forever without losing any speed
and if you don't already have an idea
what I'm talking about basically today a
couple of cheats are going to be
revealed in the game and you'll see some
of it in the live stream tonight at the
planet coaster channel as well and the
cheat that I got allows you to turn off
friction so this is basically a little
infinity symbol that's just going to
loop around forever until it runs out of
track but I made sure to at least give
it quite a bit of track that this could
at this point almost be an infinite loop
whatever the case I really just wanted
to showcase this to show you how you can
get it and what it does in game alright
now I may have lied because this G
actually consists of two different
sheets now the first one I've been told
reduces the friction of coasters to 30%
in the original value but I've also been
told that it reduces to 50% of their
value and I've also been told that the
developers are leaving this up to figure
out so I'm not exactly sure what it is I
try to figure it out later in this video
but you'll see that but basically it
slows down the friction and make sure
that your coasters actually speed up
quite a bit and all you have to do to
activate this cheat and this is actually
quite intuitive when it comes to theme
park simulation games is click on a
guest and rename them so for this key to
slow down the friction we're going to
rename a guest James Taylor who happens
to be senior designer on planet coaster
I believe and that should basically
reduce the friction to a much lower
value but the second cheat is of course
a very interesting one and this cheat
allows you to reduce the friction to
pretty much exactly zero and coasters
again as far as I know and as far as
I've tested just keep their original
speed forever and they will never slow
down unless you break them or have the
track going up and what you have to
rename a guest for this cheat is Andy
Fletcher
who
seems to be the delete designer of
planet coaster so yeah we've got to
designer guys being the rename sheets
that we have in game to either make the
friction lower or just get rid of the
friction altogether and that's basically
how the cheat works now some more things
that you really want to keep in mind
I've been told some other things and I
try to experiment as many times as I
could with these cheats these kids apply
to the entire map so when you rename a
guest Andy Fletcher it's going to turn
down friction to zero for the entire map
and when you rename a guest James
Taylor's same happens but for low
friction and you can switch between two
but I haven't been able to find a way to
get back to regular friction except if
you reload the park file because every
time I reloaded the park it pretty much
resets the friction to in-game levels so
I suppose that is the way to just reset
the cheats in general but yeah that's
basically my assumption important things
to keep in mind is that you can't set
these kids for specific coasters you can
do to any guest at any part in the map
it doesn't really matter whether they're
standing in the queue of a specific
coaster or whether they left the park in
fact the guests can leave the park and
the cheat will still be active but what
you do want to keep in mind is that the
cheat disappears when you reload the
park save so yeah let's dig into a bit
more sciency stuff when it comes to the
cheats because I'm very sure that you
want to see how those cheat works and
how much it affects the coasters so what
I've put together for a little bit or
three different versions of the same
track but each with different friction
and we'll see how that works out all
right so here the top part is with no
cheats the second is James Taylor and
the last is Andy Fletcher with no
friction whatsoever and we can very
clearly tell that any flexure is by far
the fastest the top one is losing speed
pretty quickly James Taylor is still
kind of catching up but they're both
just crashing at the end and the no
cheats one just stalls because it
doesn't have any speed left so yeah
that's pretty much how it looks and how
much they slow down relative to each
other but I also want to have a quick
look in game and
how this really effective coasters so at
the moment I've got both of the cheeks
turned off and we have a simple L logo
and the Koala b2 on wooden coaster over
here now this is pretty much the wooden
coaster as its supposed to be with
regular friction not too fast
although I did make a couple of changes
I put a few trim brakes in the middle of
the ride and while it's not too big of
an issue over here it's definitely very
slowly creeping over that hill and on
the rest of the layout it's quite simply
not going to make it the a logo though
pretty much works as its supposed to be
including a pretty good speed so I'm
pretty happy with that
but I just kind of want to see how the
cheats are going to actually change all
of this so we have our first guests in
the park here and let me just rename
this first poor person to James Taylor
and hopefully by now the wooden coaster
should have a pretty much perfect speed
at least that's what I've been going for
so basically what I've been doing is
something that's very reminiscent of
something that used to be done quite a
bit in the roller coaster in three days
and I reckon that quite a few viewers or
players of this game might as well
remember that roller coaster can three
used to have a lower friction option and
this was very commonly used by turning
it on and using brakes in order to
control the speed of your coaster a
little bit if it isn't quite making it
through a hill or an inversion or if you
want it to just be a little bit faster
you could just lower the friction and
put some brakes in there - perfectly
manage the speed and that's something
that I wanted to do with the wooden
coaster here it's just a tiny bit faster
this way than it is in Coney Beach
without the cheeks and I kind of liked
just taking the idea of turning down the
friction a little bit and controlling
the speed to what I exactly wanted to
have using the trim brakes so that's
something I just kind of did over here
and this is a way in which the idea can
turn into a disaster because this ride
is just going way too fast at this point
and would snap your neck pretty badly
especially toward the end over there so
yeah this can definitely also break your
curse
quite a bit it turns much worse if you
rename somebody into Andy Fletcher no
offense but it's a complete disaster the
wooden coaster is still somewhat okay
even though it does have these trim
rakes along the way going down to zero
friction means that without any brakes
your coaster is never going to slow down
whatsoever unless it goes up of course
there is still the effective gravity so
that's something that you might notice
but you can already notice that it's
quite a lot faster without the friction
whatsoever here and even with the trim
brakes it still really faster though but
this coaster at this point is just
insane and not something that I would
really recommend riding at this point
not that you realistically could but you
can definitely see it going a little bit
ridiculous here so yeah what's out with
these cheats unless you you know have
some really good control using brakes or
something you probably don't want to use
these cheats for realistic purposes I do
think that the James Taylor cheat it's
quite handy for doing stuff like this
like say you have a coaster and you
really just wanted to manage the speed
to what's realistic or what you really
wanted to have you can use the trim
brakes to actually get like a more
desired speed and not completely have to
rely on the in-game gravity in fiction
so that's pretty awesome
although that of course only works for
single courses on a map since the
friction options go for all coasters or
you're just gonna have to control the
speed of all your coasters but of course
and this is where I think the main
potential is even if this is not my
typical thing that I do this kid is just
really amazing if you want to go pee
bowling or torture your guests in all
kinds of ways or just make ridiculous
rides for instance I built this big log
flume and it's pretty interesting what
happens if you start testing it because
I've basically tested the cheats with
all track drives unfortunately it didn't
work with rail rights or I guess just
the Train
it also doesn't work with go-karts they
don't start going
Tivoli fast when they go downhill but it
does work with the water rides so it
works with the rapid ride but it also
works with the log flume so as soon as
it kind of hits the water it's just
going to keep on going and going to be
launched pretty fast out of that so yeah
there's definitely some very interesting
stuff that you can do with that even if
you add a little after this is just
going to keep on flying up and it's
absolutely ridiculous so some pretty fun
stuff that you could do with that kind
of thing but yeah I don't want to give
people too many ideas so I'm going to
call it a day here I want to thank you
guys for watching I want to thank the
guys at frontier so much for giving me
these cheats and allowing me to show
these kids before anybody else sees them
and kind of get a quick showcase of what
these kids do and of course have fun
playing with these kids have fun playing
the game and I'll see you guys all next
time